after five weeks of testimony from more
than 45 witnesses r kelly was found
guilty in court on monday
that's one of r kelly's attorneys after
a federal jury in brooklyn handed out
the guilty verdict to the victims in
this case
your voices were hurt
and justice was finally served real name
robert sylvester kelly the singer faced
one count of racketeering a federal
charge that focuses on organized
criminal activity and the collective
enterprise of individuals carrying out
the illegal activity according to the
initial indictment the enterprise in
this case includes kelly as well as his
managers bodyguards drivers and others
kelly was also found guilty of eight
violations of the man act a federal law
that prohibits sex trafficking the
charges date back decades and involves
six complaining witnesses since first
being indicted by a grand jury in 2019
kelly has maintained his innocence on
all charges i have pursued many sexual
predators who have committed crimes
against women and children
of all the predators that i have pursued
however
mr kelly is the worst
kelly's defense team called five
witnesses while federal prosecutors
ended up calling 45 witnesses to the
stand one of these witnesses a former
tour manager for kelly testified that
fake ids were used to clear way for him
to marry a then 15 year old aaliyah
prosecutors said that kelly wanted to
use a marriage to shield himself from
criminal charges aaliyah was one of
eight people who later died in a plane
crash in 2001. another witness told the
court that kelly prevented her from
watching the documentary series
surviving r kelly as well as
intimidating her into covering for kelly
during his 2019 sit down with gayle king
i'm fighting for my life
y'all killing me with this
robert i am michael
y'all trying to kill me sentencing fort
kelly is currently set for may 4th he's
facing potentially decades in prison
kelly is still facing additional charges
in illinois and minnesota
you